so the uk and some other european
countries are now dealing with their
worst ever monkey pox outbreak so what
do you need to know
this outbreak is really unusual most of
these cases have no connection to
west africa they haven't traveled
recently they've been within the uk but
they are picking up the infection here
and that makes it
slightly concerning for the uk health
security agency because they don't know
the source they don't know for sure how
it's spreading whether it is still in
the old way probably direct skin to skin
contact or whether there's a possibility
that there might be a mutation that
makes it easier to transmit through
coughs and sneezes and so on these are
unknowns
and that is the concern when there are
unknowns in the wake of a pandemic like
kovid it does cause people to start
wondering at the moment the risk to the
general public is low
but they are trying to make sure people
are aware of the symptoms so they come
forward if needed
the key symptoms of monkey pox are
flu-like symptoms to start with so
you've got the fever the muscle aches
and pains backache chills exhaustion but
also a very characteristic rash it looks
a little bit like chickenpox which
perhaps isn't surprising so it starts
off with as a rash which then blisters
and then scabs over over a period of two
to three weeks
well
it's likely to be most commonly spread
through direct skin to skin contact so
contact with the blisters the fluids
from those blisters and particularly
you've got a break in the skin but also
through bedding towels clothing there's
also a chance that it can be spread
through coughs and sneezes from somebody
who's got a very active
infection but that's less likely than
the direct skin to skin contact
one unusual aspect of this is that a
high proportion of the cases are gay or
bisexual men
not all
and it's important to say that this is
not a disease that's likely to be spread
by sex and it's likely to have nothing
to do with sexuality
but health authorities are trying to
raise awareness
in men that they need to be aware of the
symptoms because it may be
spreading within a sexual network men
who are having sex with other men who
may be at risk simply because
direct and intimate skin to skin contact
could be the root of transmission and
that's why they are trying to raise
awareness but that has to be balanced of
course against any potential for stigma
this could affect anybody but at the
moment they are very concerned about
spreading within the gay and bisexual
community in particular
one really interesting twist to this is
that doctors are dusting off vials of
smallpox vaccine now smallpox hasn't
been given as a jab routinely in the uk
since 1971 but there is a small
stockpile kept although it seems like a
completely different disease small parks
and monkey pox are in fact related and
the small fox vaccine is 85 effective
against monkey pox so the idea is that
not only can you give it to people who
haven't developed the symptoms yet but
you might also be able to give it to
people who have been in direct contact
and might be at risk
we are at the tail end of the covid
pandemic to see another animal virus
jumping into humans and then starting to
spread between people is obviously going
to set the alarm bells ringing for a lot
of folks now i think we need to be
careful at the moment we've got very few
cases spreading in an unusual way
so i think we need to be slightly
balanced on the one hand we do need to
find out what the source is understand
whether the virus has changed in any way
but we're not at the moment in another
covert situation this isn't a primarily
airborne disease and we do have an
effective vaccine there ready to go so
it's likely we will be able to shut this
down probably take a little bit longer
than it has in the past but i don't
think we're in the situation of another
pandemic